Tianran: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find all the differences
between McDonald's in the US and China.
This is "Food Wars."
New season, USA versus China.
I'm so excited for you guys to see this
and to meet our new cohost, Tianran.
USA versus China, let's go.
Drinks from McDonald's in
China come in three sizes,
small, medium, and big.
But for some reason the
medium is 444 milliliters,
which in Chinese basically
just means die, die, die,
which is just super unlucky,
so I guess they really
want you to either get
the large or the small.
The drinks at a US
McDonald's come four sizes,
the extra small, where'd it go?
Sorry, they forgot it.
The small, the medium, and the large.
Our large is 80.9% bigger
than China's largest soda.
Let's see if that's true.
Bound to be a little bit in the lid.
That is blasphemous!
Shame these people. Shame this clown.
Some of you over the past several years
have said something to the tune of,
it doesn't count or it's wrong
because we add the ice, or
we keep the ice in there,
and that isn't a true measurement,
which I don't believe, but fine.
For the first time ever,
I want to measure this without the ice.
I'm solving this once and for all.
So, right away you get even less soda.
Let's get this up to
exactly 32 fluid ounces.
32 ounces of Coca-Cola
in the supposed 32-ounce McDonald's cup.
I'm so sick of this.
Why are they saying 32 fluid ounces?
Look! Just say 30 or 31. It's fine.
Your move, McDonald's.
Our fries come in three sizes:
small, medium, and large.
American fries come in three sizes:
We will now weigh our largest fry.
So, what about McNuggets?
Here in China, you can only get them
as an order of five or 10,
which is really just two portions of five.
That's cute, China. Real cute.
Here in the US, we have way
many more nugget options.
Four-piece, for your infant,
six-piece, 10-piece, 20-piece,
and our largest, the 40-piece.
All the mathheads watching
will be quick to point out
that this is 300% of
China's largest portion.
So, here are all the McDonald's
menu items from China
that you won't find in the US.
Here are all the
McDonald's items in the US
you won't find in China.
Oh, my God, I've been
staring at this for so long.
This is incredible. Check out the back!
It's an origami apple! This is the best.
Let's see what we got.
A hamburger, mini fries,
a drink, a corn cup.
[gasps] Dun-dun-dun!
Po!
Oh, my God, this is way
better than the Hamburglar.
What? do I have to build Po as well?
This is -- [laughs] I'm too old for this.
Anyway, if you don't want a hamburger,
you can also change this
out for a fish fillet
or for four pieces of nuggets.
You can also get the corn cup
changed out for apple slices,
but they will cost you 1 kuai extra.
And with the juice, you can
have either apple juice,
milk, or water.
So only healthy options
here in China's McDonald's.
OK, now on to the toy.
So, this is going to take
a while. Give me a second.
Ugh.
And then something flips
out from behind his groin.
In here! It's coming together!
Oh!
It's a basketball hoop.
Oh, my God, this is ingenuity at its best.
Look, we can play hoops with this.
Three, two, one!
Whoa!
I noticed that his Happy
Meal, even the box was a toy.
In America, our Happy Meal box
is another opportunity
for an advertisement.
All-new season of "The Masked
Singer" on Fox. Check it out.
Jesus, they're shameless. These kids.
Remember before, the
extra-small fry? Found it.
More nuggets, a four-piece.
Apple slices.
Our toy is decidedly not a puzzle.
Remember when Kermit
the Frog was in there?
That was weird.
OK, what is this?
Who? What celebrity was the fox?
Oh, it was Wayne Brady.
OK, I've heard of him.
What, is his head in here?
Oddly enough, shows the stark difference
between China and the US.
Theirs has this puzzle to put together,
ours is an ad for a TV show.
[laughs and cries]
OK, so these are our
exclusive beef burgers.
Here in China, people mostly eat pork,
so I think with the beef
they've really had to
go the premium route,
so you've got some
interesting combinations.
This is the German sausage
double beef burger,
but in Chinese the name is kind of like
the "anti-vegetarian tyrant."
So they've got some pretty
aggressive marketing for this.
Imagine Terry Crews just
pulsing his pecks while he --
what is that?
Ugh.
If this is what they
call a German sausage,
then I think the Germans
will be very angry.
Here we've got a BLT double beef burger.
I'm so sad. What is this?
This is like a BLT sandwich
that's been sat at the bottom
of your bag for a week.
I'm excited about these, though.
These are the Angus
max thick beef burgers.
Now, McDonald's have done
premium collaborations
with Michelin-starred chefs in the past,
and they even have these
really super-fancy packaging.
Look at that. Double cheeseburger.
Oh, wow! Look at that.
The meat patty is thicker than my thumb.
That's a proper burger.
Mm.
Well, it's very meaty. Incredibly cheesy.
This is the double cheeseburger,
so I can understand that.
For the vast majority of Chinese people,
their understanding or
access to Western food
may really come from
fast-food restaurants.
So this is probably the
gourmet burger experience
for the vast majority of
the Chinese population.
In the US, you can get a
Quarter Pounder with cheese.
What the heck? They gave us two tops?
This is the special two-top
Quarter Pounder with cheese, apparently.
And we also have a double Quarter Pounder,
if you want to increase the meat.
If someone wants to get
their daily vegetables,
here is the Quarter
Pounder with cheese deluxe.
Swimming in mayonnaise.
We have something in the United
States called the McDouble.
If you want slightly less
cheese on a double cheeseburger,
we got you covered.
Quarter Pounder with bacon.
Every once in a while, they
just take a Quarter Pounder
and put bacon on it,
and they repackage it for a celebrity.
And these are our exclusive
chicken and fish options.
So, I want to start you off with this,
which has since become
McDonald's best spicy burger.
This is the McSpicy chicken fillet.
Apparently it's 1,000 SHU,
which is a Scoville unit,
and it's roughly equivalent
to the spiciness you get
from a spicy and numbing hot pot,
and those guys are pretty spicy.
Mm. Oh, that's delicious.
You don't feel the burn at first,
and then it's like your tongue
slowly starts to wake up,
and it's like a frog in a pot.
It slowly starts to realize
it's being boiled alive,
and by the end of this burger,
you're going to want that Coke.
Now, this is McDonald's
best-selling non-spicy burger,
the grilled chicken sandwich,
which supposedly has no growth hormones
in their chicken feed.
Very heavy on the black
pepper. Oh. Ooh, wow.
I'm very excited about this.
This is the McCrunch
chicken fillet burger,
and in Chinese the name is "katsusui."
It sounds like how it's supposed to taste.
"Ka" is kind of like "crunchy,"
and "tsu" is kind of like
the juice kind of squirting out.
So this should be both crunchy and juicy.
Ooh, that looks like a much
better piece of chicken.
Yes, yes.
I didn't get the "ka,"
probably because this has gone a bit cold,
but look at that. It is juicy in there.
OK, this is the
super-spicy chicken fillet.
Look at this guy!
You know this is going to
be super spicy. It's orange!
It's not that spicy.
[coughs] Ooh!
It's not as -- oh!
Oh, my God.
Very tasty.
Finish that, and it's
to the hospital you go. Whew.
And last but, in my opinion,
least, the double fish burger.
Chicken sandwiches.
There's something that is new-ish,
the bacon ranch McCrispy.
Hm.
It's just OK.
There's also a bacon
ranch deluxe McCrispy,
where deluxe equals more vegetables.
The McCrispy is something that
we ordered and they forgot.
And then now, piling on the vegetables,
you got the McCrispy deluxe.
Spicy McCrispy.
So they just rebranded the
crispy chicken sandwich
to be the McCrispy?
How spicy can this be?
This is not spicy at all.
So, McDonald's China has one roll option,
which is this crispy pork and
pickled bamboo shoot wrap.
Mm.
That's tasty. It's nice and crunchy.
Very spicy! [laughs] Wow.
Mm.
It's spicy. It's sour.
Anything that has Sichuan peppercorn in it
is just incredible.
Here we've got the McSpicy wings,
which come in portions of two, four,
or nine.
Straight up, I wish we had those wings.
Those wings look really good.
Also, I don't know if you've noticed,
but the decoration here on the packet,
this is a collaboration
with a streetwear brand
called Clot, or C-L-O-T,
and it uses traditional
Chinese aesthetics.
So here you've got the lucky knot,
which is sort of like a symbol
for good luck and longevity.
As Chinese as it gets.
And this is also the same
flavor as the McSpicy burger.
I don't know if there's an
accurate translation for this.
This is literally called
"such a big chicken chop."
It's about the same size as
my palm, a little bit bigger.
The McCrispy chicken.
Mm. Crispy, wow.
Mm, yes!
This is very special.
We didn't think we'd be
able to get this today.
This is the
spicy lobster-flavored chicken tenders.
The Chinese says "yao yao,"
which means you have to shake it.
Oh, let's try these babies.
There was no need to shake it at all.
There's no seasoning there at all.
It's just literally chicken tenders.
It's more of an aspiration
towards lobster, though.
And we've got crinkle-cut fries.
Oh, how I've missed you.
Mm. Nothing beats a crinkle-cut fry.
In China, we have a bunch
of different barrel options.
For example, this one is
the Golden Arches bucket,
which actually didn't come in a bucket,
they just put everything into a box.
The name actually is the
reason why we got this,
because McDonald's in China
has officially renamed to Jingongmen,
which literally translates
as Golden Arches,
and when they did that
they caught a lot of flak.
Everybody started laughing at them.
Nobody calls them the
Golden Arches in Chinese.
It's just McDonald's.
But legally they are now
known as the Golden Arches.
Featuring sauces, you know
what that means, Yuelei.
Sauce talk.
Here are all of our exclusive sauces.
Garlic chili.
That's pretty much it.
Oh, and no Sichuan sauce, either.
That's an American invention,
just like General Tso's chicken.
But here in China, you
don't really get sauces
unless you ask for them.
They come with the nuggets.
Chinese people expect food to be complete
when it arrives at your table.
You don't go and add more sauce to it.
Sauces. In the United
States, optimal for dipping.
Tangy barbecue. Spicy Buffalo.
It's the USA, so you
know we got that ranch.
Honey mustard.
Honey, which is not here.
I don't know where it is.
Mayonnaise, which also
they did not include.
Mexican-style salsa.
These are our exclusive desserts.
I am going to try every
single one of them.
We can start with the taro pie.
Taro is kind of like a cross
between sweet potato and potato.
It's often used in desserts in Asia.
You'll find them in everything
from pies to bubble tea.
It's a bit like yam with a bit of jam,
but it's subtly sweet.
For Chinese people, if you say
a dessert is not very sweet,
that's actually a compliment.
Pineapple pie, also one of my favorites.
Mm. That is heavenly.
I think I'm going to finish this.
Now I need to chew for a very long time.
So, here we've got the strawberry sundae,
which is kind of melted already,
but I'm sure it would've been
amazing when it first arrived.
An affogato and a
matcha-flavored affogato,
and then here we've got the McFlurrys.
This is the strawberry McFlurry
with Oreo cookies.
Oh, my gosh, that is perhaps
the most sinful thing
that you could have.
Oh, but it's so good.
This is just the regular McFlurry,
and here is my all-time favorite,
mango-pomelo-sago-flavored McFlurry.
Hm. It's very different
with the ice cream.
You still got the mango in there,
and the pomelo, it's
very juicy, it's tender,
like little tiny pips in there
that kind of pop when you eat them.
Oh! Just perfect.
Mm. Brain freeze. Oh!
In the US, you can get yourself
a McFlurry with mini M&M's.
For some reason, mini M&M's
taste better than regular M&M's.
I love mini M&M's. Mm.
Hot caramel sundae.
It's classic. They don't
have this in China?
God, I mean, what's more
American than an apple pie?
Look at this thing. Let's
crack that bad boy open.
We got chocolate chip cookies.
Shakes. You can get three
different types of shakes
here at a US McDonald's. Chocolate.
Classic chocolate.
Strawberry, personal favorite.
That's so good.
Vanilla, the classic.
Our exclusive drinks
include the Fuze iced tea.
We've got the Minute Maid orange McFloat,
bubble tea, soy milk,
pure milk, Ceylon black tea,
which in China we would call red tea,
which just confuses you for fun.
I'm going to go back to here
because this is the
only thing I want to try
out of all of them.
That tastes like orange juice.
It's just plain old orange juice.
In the US, you can get
yourself a Dr Pepper,
a Fanta orange and an
Orange Lavaburst, lemonade.
You can also get frozen drinks.
You can get a frozen Fanta
blue raspberry or frozen Coke.
McDonald's also has smoothies.
A mango pineapple smoothie
and a strawberry smoothie.
Yeah, they make a decent
smoothie at McDonald's.
As you can see,
we have an absolute ton of
breakfast options here in China.
I think McDonald's has done
fantastic in this regard
because the Chinese treat
breakfast as a very special meal.
We have a very similar saying to,
"Eat breakfast like a king,
lunch like a prince,
dinner like a pauper."
So, starting with the
sausage McMuffin with egg.
Always a good way to start the day.
You can get this as a double as well.
Next we have the ham muffin.
It's just literally a piece of ham,
some lettuce, and two muffins,
so I guess this would
actually be a hamburger.
You can get this as a double as well.
Next we have the grilled chicken muffin.
This chicken's been
sitting around for a while.
Next we've got the
crispy chicken McMuffin.
So this is the breakfast version of the
"such a big chicken chop."
Breakfast in the US. We have
so many breakfast options,
starting down here, the sandwiches.
Egg McMuffin. Maybe the first
fast breakfast sandwich
to ever hit the market.
Sausage McMuffin. Sausage and cheese.
If you hadn't noticed,
this is all on what we
call an English muffin,
'cause they're from England.
There's also a bacon,
egg, and cheese McMuffin.
But the option that we have most for
are the scrambled-egg burgers.
Scrambled-egg grilled chicken burger.
The scrambled egg is
very luminously yellow.
Wow, look at that.
Very peppery.
They love their pepper here, don't they?
So, the scrambled-egg sausage burger.
You'll notice the buns are different now.
We're no longer on the muffins.
We're back to regular buns.
Oh, it's squeezing out, isn't it?
Scrambled-egg cheeseburger.
This is the brightest burger
I've ever seen in my life.
It's definitely very portable.
I think that's one thing that
McDonald's has done very well,
because Chinese breakfast
traditionally is not too portable
in the sense that you need to
sit down to a lot of meals,
like if you want to eat
wonton in the morning
or if you want to eat
some soups in the morning.
This you can just take and go.
And, of course, you can
get the scrambled-egg
German-flavor-sausage burger.
Oh, at least they give you two,
as opposed to just one tiny sausage.
Biscuits, biscuits, biscuits.
Sausage and egg biscuit.
So, the biscuits are the
same breakfast sandwiches
you get in English-muffin form,
but in this biscuit form,
the American biscuit,
this dry, crumbly, buttery biscuit,
there is a bacon, egg, and cheese one.
For some reason people in this country
seem to want just a biscuit and sausage
with no sauce, no nothing.
This is as dry as if
you'd go into a barbershop
and take a handful of hair clippings
and just shove them in your
mouth. This is that dry.
In the US we have something
called McGriddles,
and McGriddles are breakfast sandwiches
where they replace the
English muffin and/or biscuit
with pancakes.
So, first of all, they got the
McDonald's logo right there.
Too hilarious.
Somehow, through the miracle of science,
was able to inject syrup
into these pancakes.
Sensational.
You can get your McGriddles
in sausage, egg, and cheese
and then just sausage.
On to what I was going to
talk about, the congee.
Congee is a very traditional
breakfast item here in China.
It's basically just rice porridge,
and it's something that is
kind of like chicken
soup for Chinese people,
in the sense that if you fall ill,
you're going to be given one
of these, plain, with nothing.
This I think is with century egg,
but the century egg,
it tastes a little bit
like a blue-cheese version of egg,
in that it's kind of
like egg that's gone off,
but in a very nice way.
And this adds a nice
savoriness to the congee.
You can also get it with
pickles and bamboo shoots.
And if you're going to get congee,
then usually you need to pair it
with what they've called
an "Asian dough stick."
This is what we call a youtiao,
which is literally a stick of fried dough.
These are absolutely amazing
when paired with stuff like soy milk
and, of course, with congee.
You know, you need to eat these fresh.
Deep-fried, they are so incredibly crispy.
Oh, wow, well done, McDonald's.
Like, 10 hours later,
these are still crispy.
I'm very impressed but
also a little bit worried
because they should never be
this crispy after that long.
I wonder what they've put in here.
Last but not least, our
German sausages again.
It's not just sandwiches, you guys.
We also have something in the US,
the Big Breakfast, which
is totally in disarray.
This is like the advertising
for this breakfast.
I'm sorry?
The Big Breakfast with pancakes.
You can also get hotcakes, aka pancakes.
There's no way they're back
there, like, ladling the ...
right? There's no way they're doing that.
These have to be premade and
they just heat them up, right?
So, hotcakes and sausage.
Oh, and they both come with syrup,
so you know what we gotta do.
Oh-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho, yeah!
We also have a
morning wrap with ham.
The wrap itself is basically frozen solid.
We can exchange that with sausage,
which is also frozen.
It's almost like a piece of art now,
like you're supposed to look
at it instead of eating it.
Wow, frozen in time.
US McDonald's have
sausage breakfast burritos.
I mean, I can't even unfold,
I'm just, like, ripping it apart.
You got scrambled eggs, the sausage,
it comes with Mexican-style salsa.
Hey, McDonald's, it's actually pretty good
considering that this is, like,
probably the furthest
you can get from salsa
and still legally be
able to call it salsa.
If you're not trying to
completely destroy your insides
first thing in the morning,
you can get yourself
fruit and maple oatmeal.
Seems like your breakfast
is trying to escape
your body an hour later,
might actually be able to hold this down.
Et voilà, ze options from le bakery.
So, we have macarons.
Right now we have two different flavors,
chocolate and berries.
These actually look really legit.
Pat yourself on the back.
This is really good.
And these things are lamingtons.
I've never actually had lamingtons.
Apparently, they're basically
Australian sponge cakes
which are covered in coconut flakes,
and this is a lemon-flavored one.
Surprisingly addictive.
We have the McCafé bakery.
At the McCafé bakery, you
get, you know, sweet treats,
not necessarily for breakfast
but probably leaning more
towards breakfast time.
Ba-bam, blueberry muffin.
A cinnamon roll with
cream cheese frosting.
It looks like it's squishy.
It most certainly is not.
I mean, come on, who doesn't
love an apple fritter?
An apple fritter is a doughnut
that tastes like apple
and is shaped like it was
just squoze in someone's hand
for some strange reason.
These are our McCafé drink options,
starting with the extra-milky
latte with oat milk.
A latte is two-thirds milk,
and then you add oat milk in there,
I don't think we're going
to have much coffee.
Oh. Oh, wow, that is surprisingly good.
In China, oat milk has
really, really taken off
because a lot of people did
not grow up drinking milk.
A lot of Chinese people
are lactose intolerant.
And so oat milk is definitely
a very healthy alternative,
and that's why we have the
extra-strong chocolate with oat milk.
You can also get this without oat milk.
Extra-strong matcha milk.
Extra-strong matcha --
oh, we have so much matcha.
Extra-strong chocolate smoothie,
extra-strong milk and vanilla smoothie,
and the matcha milk with matcha jelly.
Matcha, matcha, oh, I'm going to --
We absolutely love matcha here
in China. I don't know why.
It tastes like grass and frozen grass.
Coffees and coffees and
coffees and coffees.
McDonald's has a assortment
of featured drinks,
espresso drinks, mochas, iced lattes.
Let's get all that on the screen.
See? All these things.
This is the cold brew. This is so strong.
I think each of you should
eventually take a sip.
You will not believe how
strong the cold brew is.
Oh, my God.
French vanilla latte.
This is the exact
opposite. This is so sweet.
Mocha. Who doesn't want hot chocolate
first thing in the morning?
Hilarious, people are buying that.
Ooh, this is the premium roast coffee.
I know I've been kind of dissing on it,
but their actual coffee, the
actual McDonald's coffee,
I think is very good.
They're a good contender in
the coffee game, I think,
in the fast-food coffee game.
Especially the horrible
PR nightmare they had
when they, like, destroyed
that lady's crotch
with their superhot coffee.
It is a comeback story, McDonald's.
Almost killing a woman
with second-degree burns
from boiling-hot coffee
to these nice little fun café drinks.
I would happily pour
this all over my crotch.
You can get the iced-coffee drinks.
Don't like this. This is the mocha.
McDonald's in China also
has a late-night menu.
They only have one item,
but this is worth it.
I got it last night. These
are marinated chicken bones.
They don't sound very appealing,
but the Chinese name
is wordplay on an idiom
which kind of means "the
highest level of artistry."
And when I opened up this box,
[gasps]
I literally heard angels going, "Aah!"
This is actually a street food
from someplace up in Northeast
China called Shenyang.
Chinese people love fiddly stuff,
and meat on the bone is
just that much more tasty.
Ah, still incredible, even cold.
You know, the box actually
says "marinated chicken bones."
"Be careful, it may contain bones."
And you're actually supposed
to spit the bones out,
but I'm having so much
fun eating this thing,
I actually eat the bones too.
It's spicy, it's sour, it's sweet.
Ah, and just absolutely divine.
I can see how people would be
inspired after eating this.
So, McDonald's came to China in 1990,
and then it opened in Beijing in '92.
Back then, that was the largest
McDonald's in the world.
They had 700 seats.
On opening day, they served 40,000 people.
And people didn't go there for the food.
It was a place to be seen.
Like, McDonald's was a window to the West.
It was a cosmopolitan place
to experience capitalism, in a way.
But over time it became
a trendy hangout spot
for city kids after school.
They'd go there to do their homework.
It still very much is middle class.
I remember actually when I came
to visit China 20 years ago,
my aunts greeted me at the
airport with bags of McDonald's,
and I was actually kind of offended
that they would bring junk food to meet me
as opposed to real Chinese food,
but for them McDonald's
was the best of the best.
It was all the prestige.
Hey, to me, McDonald's,
when it comes to fast food,
is No. 1 in the US, dare I say the world.
If you just want a good hot meal
where you know exactly what
it's going to taste like
and get it and go, McDonald's never fails.
Waiting in line, getting
it at the drive-through,
you get it lickety-split.
Now they leaned really big
into delivery since COVID,
and, man, McDonald's is
showing up right away,
and I love it. It's dangerous.
I can't remember the last time
I've eaten inside at a McDonald's.
So, I usually dine in at McDonald's,
but I find that in China
they focus more on delivery,
and they promise to get
everything delivered
within 30 minutes, which
they actually keep to,
and that's incredibly impressive.
Last night I ordered the chicken carcass.
It took 28 minutes.
Got a Big Mac earlier.
That was 10 minutes.
So they're very, very punctual.
They're also open for very long,
from 7 till 10 p.m.,
and there are many 24-hour branches,
so extremely convenient.
Now, McDonald's is an American brand,
so they have American
classics on the menu,
hamburgers, chicken sandwiches,
but they kind of
assimilated and made popular
the burger culture in this country.
It's hard to say, because I feel like
the American taste is McDonald's.
I think McDonald's has actually adapted
pretty well to Chinese tastes.
Besides the McSpicy burger and wings
and the grilled chicken sandwich,
which have all become bestsellers,
McDonald's actually
uses chicken thigh meat
instead of breast meat in
all of its chicken burgers,
except for the McChicken.
And I think that's because Chinese people
think chicken breast is dry,
and they've also got lots
of time-limited specials
when it comes to the desserts,
like the mantou burger,
which is kind of like a Chinese bun,
and even cilantro sundae.
McDonald's, everyone's
going after McDonald's.
Burger King's been going after McDonald's
since, what, the '60s?
Every burger chain
try to get some sort
of edge on McDonald's.
We're fancier, we got
different varieties of stuff.
McDonald's is No. 1,
here, now, and forever.
The McDonald's logo should be
on the American flag, dammit!
So, China is McDonald's
second-largest market
by store count, after the US.
In China, there are over
5,000 McDonald's locations,
but KFC has over 9,000.
They actually came here first,
so it's KFC, then McDonald's,
then a local brand called Dicos,
which does both fried chicken and burgers,
so they're really just
fighting an uphill battle.
In China, a Big Mac costs 25 yuan.
A Big Mac in the US costs $5.29.
Make it a Big Mac meal
with a medium fries and
medium Coke, and it's 36 yuan.
If you want to go large,
that's 4 yuan extra
for a grand total of 40 yuan.
If you make it a meal
with a medium fries and medium drink,
price goes up to $9.29.
Upgrade that to a large, and it's $10.79.
Our Big Mac large meal costs 86% more.
So our Big Mac meal is cheaper,
but at the same time
the average daily wage
of a cabby in Beijing is
about 200 yuan, give or take,
and so this would be 20% of their salary.
So it's still not really something
that you would eat on a regular
basis, but maybe splurge on.
Let's talk nutrition.
This is that very Big Mac, again.
In the US, it's 590 calories
and all this stuff.
In China, our Big Mac has 524 calories,
26 grams of fat, 45 grams of carbs,
27 grams of protein,
and 877 milligrams of sodium.
What if we did a combo?
Starting with the medium fries,
this adds 320 calories to the meal,
and all this stuff.
While a medium fries in
China contains 290 calories,
13 grams of total fat,
35.9 grams of carbs,
we're not sure if it contains any sugars,
4 grams of protein,
and 252 milligrams of sodium.
But you need something to drink.
Add in a medium Coke to that,
and this kicks your meal
up another 210 calories.
We'll do the same.
Here's everything in a
medium Coke in China.
148 calories. That leaves the grand total
for the China meal at 962 calories.
While in the US, the total
ends up looking like this.
1,120 calories and all this other stuff.
Get a load of that sodium, though.
Guh!
Take the box out. You
can't throw away the box.
Some kind of hoop.
Just trying to build
some more Yao Mings here.
Give me a couple decades.
Now, usually when a foreign
brand comes to China,
they get a Chinese name too,
and sometimes it's a transliteration,
and sometimes they get
really nice meanings as well.
For McDonald's, the
Chinese name is Maidanglao,
which is a transliteration,
but you could also kind
of take it to mean that
wheat is obligated to work for you.